[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett
and i'm link this week at the round
table of dim lighting
man we hate to see you guys fight
we hate to know that you're experiencing
conflict that you're in
arguments with with one another those
arguments might be
life-altering or ridiculous in nature it
doesn't matter to us all that matters to
us is that
it's resolved and that's what we're
that's what we pride ourselves on
being able to ability to resolve
conflict to save
relationships save marriages uh
by giving you the official i would say
restore
relationships yeah and that the official
answers
to these questions yeah there is an
objective truth
and we have it and we have we have we
have it
for every single one of these questions
actually we have not discussed these
beforehand
we may disagree but one of us will win
the argument and if it comes to blows
then so be it ha
the the prompt we put out there follow
us on twitter
talk to us using your biscuits you can
be
shouted out on the show your dirty
laundry can be aired
in front of everyone and to prove that
hey
we're all the same
okay try to put a positive spin on that
so people don't get scared that we're
going to make fun of them
got an argument conflict or disagreement
you can't resolve
let us know and we'll handle it on an
upcoming year biscuits
that was the post and now this is the
show full circle
wow it's happening it's like magic
before we get into this
um there's another thing that is
that ear biscuits at the hub of besides
the hubbub
hub of besides biscuits is the hubbub
uh resolving conflicts and that is any
news related to the window in my
shower has to funnel through
ear biscuits it might then go off into i
don't know
a vlog that we make when we were making
those remember that
that was great that was a fun one are
you making the window bigger
i have an update for the full body on
the window boy i'm thinking about yeah
as you probably know the window is in my
shower
and it's only you know it it's from the
collarbone to the top of the head
okay yeah so it leaves a little bit to
be desired
thank you that's a that's a that's a
nice guy it's one of those things that
when you sell your house
and somebody comes into it people are
going to have questions about the window
in the shower they're going to
the first reaction is going to be
negative but then every
when they buy my house and every
experience they have with that window
is going to be positive i have another
positive point because like i said i
pushed for this window to be installed
ever you know christy was scratching her
head the contractor was scratching his
head everybody was scratching all types
of stuff
except for me i was scratching the itch
that was the desire to have
a view while taking a shower and it goes
beyond yeah okay
yes there was a problem with my
neighbor's scene i gotta
i think i've given a little bit of an
update there
i have video to go along with this
so i'm gonna have my phone ready to pull
out okay um
let's see where do i start of course my
bathroom's on the second floor
uh and then the rest
and my master bedroom is on the second
floor not everything else is on the
first floor
and when i'm looking out the window i'm
kind of looking over my
roof into the into the distance
um i was in lily's room so i was
downstairs
i was talking to her and she's got her
room was like
she only had this one window and then
because of the bushes beside the window
it was always so dark in there i was
like you need a
sunroof you need a skylight
they call it so actually as part of this
construction with the remodel of the
house
we also put a skylight in her room
oh i didn't know that yeah she's it's a
it's a little square
it's how however big that is i don't
know
uh two by two it's a small one 18 by 18
maybe 18 by 18 maybe
and i look up there like man your your
uh skylight is dirty
she's like i never really look at it i
was like well
how much sunlight because that's a
putting on a skylight in a bedroom
means that now the sun comes into her
bedroom when the sun comes up which is
not a teen
teen thing it has a shade on it i got
i i'm like you know what i'ma get i'm
gonna optimize this
i'm gonna get one with a shade with a
remote so yeah
she has a she has her own little shade
and the skylights in our living room
i also put shades on those because when
it gets real hot
it gets real hot you don't want it to
get too hot so you close those shades
in that big part of the room um
she didn't seem to be too fazed by it
but it just stuck in my head i'm like
um my role is to keep the skylights
clean
i've squeegeed all of the skylights
before but then the outside
i got to get a ladder i got to get my
window squeegee i got to like make my
suds i've got to
bring another thing of water that
doesn't have suds to rinse it off
because i can't get the hose all the way
up there
it's a problem so when i realized man
you're due for a cleaning
i just kind of logged it away i'm like
you know maybe six weeks from now i'll
get up there
and i'll squeegee the skylights again
and i'll enjoy it
but then lo and behold the next day
i'm in my shower showering
and i just found myself thinking about
the skylight now if when i look at my
window i cannot see
lily's skylight right but if i get if i
open my window and look down i i could
see it if i if i really tried
but you have to really try to see it so
i just want to preface it with if i'm in
my shower i can't look down into my like
daughter's bedroom that would just be
weird
strange well it's also probably a
translucent
uh it's clear you can see you could see
in it but
the angles are such that you can't but
i didn't think hold on
i've got a shower head here that
that comes you know it's got this i've
got the shower head above like the rain
shower head but then i got the one that
i can take off the wall and like the
wand
i can shower i can shower up different
places and under different places and
rent
i my rent game is there should be laws
against top no there should be laws
against people like you you should see
me
rinsing myself i should get a video of
that
but it occurred to me i can spray
i can i can wash lily's skylight while
i'm in the shower
this is first of all let me just say
doubtful i doubt that you're going to
get the pressure that you
that is required to pull this off but
you're also going to freak your daughter
out so i'm also going to show you a
video because
i knew that's what you were going to say
here we go
all right you know what time it is it's
time for a
shower update the window's still there
and there's always something new to
discover
hold on are you naked in this window
because there was a reflection
on the neighborhood i'm shirtless fence
so it's harder to see me yeah so the
neighborhood effects that's the update
there
of course what i discovered was
right down there is a sunroof
sunroof
isn't this exciting not really but did
you uh
did you just lily home at this point i
think she was sleeping
put this thing on
i could watch my whole roof see i can't
quite well not really
yeah you got to get the yeah not enough
pressure
oh yeah blast
and
i'm cleaning the sunroof for my shower
did this wake her up
uh yeah she had to think oh it's raining
she thought she was like wake up lily
it's raining
did it work did it clean it
pretty great yeah pretty great
yeah yeah it did work it cleaned it man
and then it's just a testament of how
often it
doesn't rain in california that's right
a little bit of
low pressure shower water is going to
clean clean the uh yet another reason
that that
window in the shower is is perfect
i went to work before lily got up and
when i got home
she was like dad were you on the roof
washing
my skylight this morning
and i was like no i was in my shower
[Laughter]
i washed your sunroof from my shower
how did that make her feel not surprised
yeah i think was
pretty much it you know so is she the
only one yeah is she the only one who
got
a skylight she's the only one that
needed it
okay uh she and she doesn't have a
window in her shower either
she's not asking for one don't know
what's up but
i just feel like it's my duty to keep
you filled in on
the continual enjoyment that i'm having
in my shower
i thought that you're i i was hoping
well i like to believe that the neighbor
did see this happen
i i like to think that the neighbor has
has a blog
yeah like a blog spot and it's called my
neighbor
my my strange neighbor dot blogspot.com
and they are they both contribute to it
the husband and the wife contribute to
it
yeah and um you know the it's not hasn't
been updated many times
this is like at most every six months
which is a typical blogspot cadence
and uh the latest entry is like
you won't believe what came out of that
window this time
you know it's like how would you explain
it because they probably
the skylight so they just like see this
man
they just see him like squirting his
roof
like changing the pressure and they're
like what is this fool doing
i'm so glad we put that fence up it was
so much easier
to wash i mean i i would like to have
been able to squeegee it
so i think what i'm going to do is i'm
going to get a really ex
long extendable pole with a squeegee on
it but what i'm gonna keep that in this
but you have all the other skylights too
yeah that are getting dirty at the same
rate you know you're right presumably
you're right i didn't want to bring that
up but yeah you don't sponge it
well i would think you would take like
one of those mitts that you like wash a
car with
and and have you have you done one of
these have you done i would think you'd
be real i know you're into cleaning
i got a special squeegee and on one side
it's got like the scrubber
with it has a long sponge across it
yeah and you you scrub it with that and
then you flip it over
and you squeegee it yeah because it's
sort of like sort of a wash and drying
one
yeah you know just like the people here
in windshields
who wash your windshield at a red light
that doesn't happen anymore without you
asking but yeah that hasn't happened in
a long time
no huh all right so that's my update
don't worry about it i've still got it
we're still
we're still good we're still good
uh how's your eyesight well
you can test it unofficially with the
good mythical morning
eye chart shirt look at this i mean
people are gonna look at this and
they're gonna try to figure out what it
says and then you're gonna
tell them oh good mythical morning is
you should myth what does that say on
the bottom
i call morning where's this on the
bottom
as you can see we can't oh as you can
see we can't yeah okay
look nice little slogan i mean it's just
read line one
g it's tough to get a graphic that is
this wide
i want to put the yeah to get a number
that we had to because that was accurate
we had to be accurate
usually you don't go much past the
nipple but this these numbers are two
inches outside of my nipple
which is which is really impressive we
cannot be contained
by standard printable areas
mythical.com this isn't some
print-on-demand thing
i mean we do that too as well but that's
not what this is
no this is a we demanded it be printed
right totally different
mythical.com good work team
ably abby bigler uh to help us settle
this argument
is it less gross to borrow your
significant other's toothbrush
than to borrow a friend's toothbrush
i say yes my boyfriend says no they're
equally gross
your boyfriend is wrong this is not a
difficult one by any means
i mean is it they're not equally gross
but they are both very gross they're
both gross
if i had to choose one person to
to brush my teeth with their toothbrush
i would choose my wife right
well and that i think the answer is
simple because
you're regularly assuming that you have
a healthy marriage regular
regularly swapping spit with your wife
you know
so you basically have i would think
there is a
culture of bacteria that has actually
been influenced both ways
in your mouth and your partner's mouth
because that's what happens when you
just
constantly i mean like my wife and i are
just constantly making out
like french kissing constantly french
kissing right when we wake up
right before i leave first thing when i
get home right before we go to bed
i mean and it doesn't always lead to sex
i mean sometimes it's just french
kissing let's be real for a second
let's be real for a second right it's
like i mean it's not really detached
from foreplay in in my home there's not
a lot of just make out sessions
and when you've been married 20 years
yes the makeout sessions usually lead
to completion a complete sort mail
sorting session
right but i say that usually i i would
say for me
i you know i would say almost
exclusively at this point what if you
get into an argument though
sometimes that'll that'll put it stop
the thing oh oh
so then it just counts as a make out
session
only if something else some external
factor
gets in the way but you know what we're
saying you kiss your partner and
therefore your mouth is touching their
mouth directly on a regular basis and so
there are two things about
scheduled let's just let's talk about
just french kissing for a while let's
not get back to toothbrush because i
scheduled french kissing yeah what do
you think about that
it's kind of like you know i don't like
scheduling anything
but then it you schedule things when
they never happen otherwise
well i mean it happens but it happens
as a and then it stops like we're just
having a make-out session
like i'll say we just talk about you and
your wife we i'm sp
i'm referring to me and my wife you and
christy are having a makeout session
okay and that's it i think that's gonna
require some planning
uh you know like some uh expectation
management i think it does happen
i think i think i need to be
biologically ready for that i think it
does happen but i think
that would be fine i i do usually
interpret it or
let's just be honest i like to believe
that it is contributing to foreplay even
if it's like 4 p.m
and i know that the male sorting is not
going to happen anytime soon if it's
making out happening
what i'm thinking is well here we go are
you telling this is a deposit in the
bank now
i'm bringing zero judgment into this
this is all curiosity
because for me this never happens are
you saying that like
you and jesse might pass each other in
the house and then
you'll just start making out has that
ever really happened yes
there's no way right yes what
really yeah i mean like like like like
french kissing well if you cut it if
you're gonna kiss like christy not do it
like the friends chris and i will hug
and we will kiss each other on the mouth
i'm not saying it's like
normal thing but we're not gonna go into
like a make-out
session well okay when you say session
how long is a session i'm saying that
like there might be like a forget
session
tongue tongue the tongue will breach
yeah no i mean like okay be more
specific
my tongue will go into her mouth and her
tongue will go into my mouth
you want me to draw you a diagram hey no
i'm cool with
what you've told me i'm not saying that
this is no not often at all but i'm
saying
you're just saying you just said it
never happens no it happens
it has happened i it doesn't it doesn't
it never happens to us unless
and i'm not saying it it's automatically
foreplay
but you have to be in it only happens to
us in a zone
i think it i think that's true yeah okay
listen i don't want to paint
an incorrect picture here that this is
like i don't want to walk in your
every time you turn around i'm making
out with my wife
that's and i'm sure that there are some
couples where that that happens
i'll be honest that i think i kind of
represent
you know a little bit of a stereotypical
husband
you know situation which is like if
that's happening
i'm kind of thinking about it in
reference to what it might lead to
right to be honest with you that's how i
think about it and even if your
brain's not thinking about it that way
the rest of your body biologically is
uh and so but there are times
when it would just be a thing that just
happens
and doesn't lead to anything and that's
not what the expectation is because of
where we're at or when
you know i mean also things like being
on a date sometimes
there'll be some making out that happens
on a date like
in the car okay in the car yes in
privacy
i'm still picturing like what is this
gonna be pda at the date table
that's what i wanted to clarify because
that's what i was picturing
i mean not that i was picturing my wife
would be okay with us making out
in like in like a restaurant because she
she would
i would think that she would think that
that was like oh he's
he's not scared to show his his love for
me
in this place but i just you know it's
kind of a mclaughlin thing we're a
little bit sensitive to pda or pdoa
as my dad says he puts the oh what it
public display of
oh yeah thank you you had to tell me he
always does the oh
pdoa videoa no no place for pdoa no i
you know what i i hereby resolve to
tongue kiss my wife
period because you don't care about pdoa
what people think about it
pedoa padoa
[Laughter]
pdoa wow you know i
i thought more highly of your father no
but here's the thing
it's it's not i refuse to believe
because my dad doesn't have those things
that he says that are like right i've
never heard of
the incorrect pronunciation of something
so
i choose to just believe that he
actually is correct that people just
drop the o for
for you know illegitimate reasons all
right you want to go back to
toothbrushes
i'm but it here's a i yes
i will tongue kiss my wife but that
doesn't mean i want to use her
toothbrush because i
actually want her to use her toothbrush
and me to use my toothbrush before that
now that's not a requirement we don't
like
we don't have to like detox before we
have intimacy
but but if you're on vacation and you
realize that you forgot your tooth
more often than not we're going to brush
our teeth before
there's any like make out well okay of
course
you're married but
um if you're on vacation and you realize
that like first night you're like crap i
forgot my toothbrush
i know exactly where it's sitting right
there on the counter
what do you do the front desk will
usually give you one
100 first of all i'm not solving the
problem
right then i'm going to bed and then i'm
going to bed without brushing my teeth
because i don't think that that's that
big
i might i would probably uh swish
or i would like if if i wasn't just
going to bed but if i if we were
you know if if there was going to be
some making out
and let's just say that's it huh nothing
else
you know i might use i might use some
tooth paste on my finger
that's okay that's exactly you know for
sure i got you know anything to freshen
up
but if there's not going to be making up
i would do that before i use christy's
toothbrush
even in that there's many things that i
would do before i would use jesse's
toothbrush and i don't think i've ever
used her toothbrush because i do believe
that it is gross and i do believe that
it is grosser than kissing
but if i have because it's a cleaning
process that wasn't the question
is it less gross to borrow your
significant other's toothbrush than to
borrow a friend's toothbrush absolutely
yes
nothing to argue about it's still gross
i think her boyfriend
is saying no they're equally gross
okay they're not abby
you're you're right but you know what i
don't
some arguments you just you don't need
to win
is this one of those arguments well no i
think that she won this one
yeah we think she won but i don't know
if he's gonna if she needs to
pray there's something going on that she
didn't i think there's something under
this
question that she did not reveal which
is i think
that she either has used his toothbrush
or is like he forgot his toothbrush and
she was like just use mine and he's like
no that's gross and then they got into
this argument
so whether or not you should use your
significant other's toothbrush is a
different question than the one that was
asked here we're just answering the
question that was asked
and talking about a lot of other stuff i
would not
use i i i think that i have used
christy's toothbrush
but i think it was an accident but then
i didn't feel horrible about it
yeah especially if you get the water
real hot yeah
when you're done with your toothbrush
you really clean it do you really clean
it under the hot water afterwards
i could really clean it i do not really
clean it under the hot water
what do you clean it with just the water
oh
okay you look at i look at it and make
sure that there's no like white guns
well the cool thing about and this not a
sponsor right now but the the quip
uh black toothbrush the bluetooth one is
that you can see
any little residue of toothpaste because
it's black and so it makes you clean it
even better
oh yeah let's move on though
ashley sizemore is it okay to leave your
glass on the counter
with the intention to use it again later
or do you put it in the dishwasher and
get a new glass sincerely the family who
disagrees
wow this is really this is so relevant
yeah this is tough to to uh my own
experience because
it's home i i i'm on two minds of this
because first of all
my family
and i'm gonna say mostly my kids
they use so many cups and glasses so
quickly
and they they just put them in the sink
i mean they don't even put them in the
we haven't even gotten our kids to put
things in the dishwasher unless we're
there and tell them to do it right
but like they'll be like oh look there's
12 glasses
we could have guests and then like the
next morning i'd be like where's our
freaking glass
no glasses and they're all in the sink
upside down dirty when the dishwasher's
empty
right i mean but but what i do
because first of all i like to
i'm just like i'm not going to
contribute to the mayhem
so what i do nine times out of ten
if i use a glass in the kitchen take the
glass
i drink some water i immediately wash
the glass and put it back on the counter
but put it back on the shelf that's
great nine times out of ten wow
now the additional one time out of ten
especially if it's like a saturday and
i'm like i'm gonna come back here
i'll drink it and then i'll put my glass
on the counter
at a certain place like behind the sink
because i'm like my kids are not gonna
they
they're not gonna do this no one's gonna
grab so it's your secret spot where you
know you can go back to it
so i will do this yeah i i have a secret
spot
i mean i i carry around a water bottle
in my own house
so you don't need this you don't you
don't need them and then we drink a lot
of cans
uh you know to a fault but um
i think there's an answer here in
everybody i think there should be a rack
kind of like when i was talking about
the pill box for every day of the week i
think there needs to be a
a drying rack that has a
a spot for each person's cup to be
after they use it to to rinse it and
then put it upside down on a drying rack
that's compact enough to be hidden
somewhere because this is ugly you don't
want this out on the counter
you want to have behind a cabinet you
just want to have
this is this is my glass every person
only has
one glass and then that's the only glass
they can use
and they always know where it is and
they're in charge of it
so the glasses aren't communal anymore
and there should be a drying rack i hate
the breath
i hate to break it to you i've tried a
version of this three times
and i was the instigator of it and i was
the the only enforcer of it
we didn't do exactly what you just
described but i told jesse i said
these boys use so many glasses
we need to get glasses that either have
their names on them
or have like a design on them and it's
like this is your glass
picture if they don't know their name
and this is your you don't want to have
any excuses right
don't remember my name it doesn't work
it doesn't work because what do they do
they use the glass
that has their name on it and they put
it in the sink and then when they want
something else to drink they go to
another glass
you cannot get them to cooperate they
are impervious
to systems they have not experienced
enough of the consequences
of not completing the cycle
of a glass they if they would if they
washed and put away
all the glasses if they cared about that
somehow or were held accountable to it
you know when there's stuff in the sink
i have to i call
i call them back and bring them back in
there and i say can you put
put this in the dishwasher you made this
mac and cheese
at three o'clock in the afternoon or
three o'clock in the morning
and you left it all here i need you to
move this
in here i need you to complete your task
it doesn't work it is hopeless i you
kind of have a choice to make as a
parent
i'm not going to bring them back into
the kitchen to try to teach them a life
lesson or am i going to just
try to keep them alive until they go to
college and then they'll figure that
[ __ ] out on their own
right that's kind of where i'm at but i
will say i sometimes i even go into the
whole
like typical dad
rant where i'm like do you have any idea
how many children there are in the world
that if i were to bring them a glass
with their name on it like it would be
like the day
the best day of their year oh gosh you
know what i'm saying like the whole
thing that our parents used to do to us
about where the kid's starving and stuff
and i'm like
this is a privilege we went through the
trouble to go to this website to get
this
cup with your name on it and this would
be a treat
to so many children out there but you're
just taking it
and treating it like any other glass
it's a personalized glass
and you need to get with the program
yeah it does that doesn't work either by
the way if you're a young parent
and you want to go on one of the rants
where you can pair your children
children's plight with the plight of
other children in the world
it doesn't work no it doesn't mean you
won't try it many times but it does not
work
so ashley you're right it is okay to
leave your glass on the counter with the
intention to use it
she did not say what she her position
was no she didn't say
uh she just said a family who disagrees
i think you're in charge of the complete
cycle of the glass
and as you can leave it out as long as
you
ultimately are the one to put it away at
the end of the day
what i want to say is that you all have
to agree on a system but if my family is
any
uh you know guide for this they will not
agree on a system and this is an
intractable problem that will cause
strife in your family for many years
just remove all glasses
andrew khan tweeted at us nesquik
powder or chocolate syrup
and you know there were a bunch of food
related
conflicts and i realized
we can we could we could get in on these
but
there's a whole other podcast produced
at mythical called a hot dog is a
sandwich where
mythical chef josh and nicole they
they have every wednesday they get it
they get into a food debate
right and they actually know what
they're talking about you know tacos
versus burritos
uh crunchy peanut butter versus schmooze
i mean
the name the name of the podcast the hot
dog is a sandwich is based on a very
famous food debate
so itself so we're going to resist the
temptation to
to infringe on their territory because i
love what they're doing over there if
you haven't checked it out
um definitely check it out start with
the most recent one work your way
backwards
can i can i agree with that can i um but
we are going to
suggest what i would call a third way
you know sometimes there's two
conflicting
powder chocolate syrup or what third way
that i'm going to propose
and that is actual chocolate and here's
why i'm going to say this
we were just going to say you could just
buy chocolate milk which is great by the
way so my for that's a treat i haven't
had in years
my favorite hot chocolate chocolate well
okay
and i'm about to well i don't know
you've got weird opinions because i do
have an answer and i think it's one of
these two
um the best hot chocolate that i've ever
had
hands down is uh mike mccarthy's wife
jenny
will do this yeah that's decadent hot
chocolate
in a crock pot right and it's just
it's milky it's so great and
it has made me not like any other hot
chocolate
and she briefly described to me what was
in it i didn't listen that
intently but the one thing i did here if
you want to make it you just wanted to
drink it yeah the one thing i did here
is that it's got
actual chocolate i think actual
chocolate chips
in it so it literally is composed of
melted chocolate
and other ingredients including milk not
i don't think white any water sees this
thing
i think it's milk anyway so i think the
third way is
actual chocolate and it is the best way
well that doesn't answer this question
hot chocolate right that's not
that's they're talking about chocolate
milk not hot chocolate
that's true so you know none of that
matters
that's true yeah i was thinking of a
different beverage
but you can make hot chocolate with
these things i mean it just goes to show
you
what heat can do to a beverage making
something totally different
so yeah the third option is just buying
actual chocolate milk
there was this cheap
uh carton of chocolate milk that my mom
used to buy
and it was so thick as a kid oh i miss
it so much it was like
borden brand well you know the ones oh
god
the ones in the glass bottle the ones on
the glass are really good uh
like one time looks like the milkman
would drop it off yeah we were hanging
out with julian smith
and he was like guys you got to have
this was that
it was eggnog eggnog but it was from the
same farm it was from this farm it's
like the so-and-so farm and they do a
really good hot chocolate
last night i went link neal old school
um of course in high school and in
college
every night i would have a spoonful of
peanut butter
and then i would take the hershey syrup
the chocolate syrup here andrew
and i would you know i'd pour it in and
i would
ding ding ding ding ding mix it up
um but back and i did that last night
oh it was great um
ironic i love eating is that why you
chose this question because you did it
last night
it's fresh on my mind but as a
as a middle schooler and grade schooler
i at my nana's house
she had the nesquik powder and i would
eat that every day huge glasses
eat it i i yeah i
eat my chocolate milk with a spoon weird
i i don't drink it i i eat the peanut
butter off the spoon and then i use the
spoon
don't describe it it just is going to
annoy me and that's how i eat my that's
how i eat my smoothie now as a middle
aged man
every morning i eat my smoothie with a
spoon because of this nostalgia
i gotta say i think nesquik powder is my
official answer
yeah interesting even though we have uh
hershey's syrup
at the house it tells you to keep it in
the refrigerator which drives me nuts is
this because of taste
because clearly something that's a syrup
is easier to mix than something that's a
powder
uh it's not it's not easier to mix if
your
syrup is not room temp or warm if it's
refrigerated and cold it's harder to mix
it still works but it doesn't mix as
readily as powder
but it it tastes different it's a
different taste
it's probably a more manufactured
synthetic taste
i'm talking about the powder here but i
have a nostalgic affinity to that
um it's closely related to my
kraft american sliced cheese
nostalgic affinity i i opened my
refrigerator
two days ago and there was a there was a
stack
like that whole you know i hadn't seen
this in years we have not had
individually packaged sliced craft
american cheese in our fridge yeah i
mean
over 10 years it's just not something we
have right yeah my wife doesn't
either i knew it had to do i didn't even
ask i know i had to
lily went to the grocery store and
bought it and i know it has something to
do with tick-tock
i didn't even ask oh it's probably
because they you throw it on people's
like you throw it on people's foreheads
and throw it on babies and stuff she was
going to put it on top
of another type of mac and cheese that
she's but you
but you haven't seen that you know what
i'm talking about yeah you take a yeah
slice of american cheese and you throw
it on a stranger yeah that's funny but i
that's not why she was doing it i tasted
a piece and boy it's
it's um it's good it's good but it's not
cheese
speaking of uh josh on this mythical
chef josh has very strong opinions about
american cheese and
i agree with him you know he's not a
food snob at all and
and you know what lily's talking about
using it for
putting it on top of uh mac and cheese
which by the way she didn't like it by
the by the way she did not like it
she didn't like it was with the way she
used it she didn't like the tape she
didn't like the experience
and then did she put it on because she's
got lincoln to try
because recently i i smoked that that
pork shoulder and had you guys over for
it and yeah and
lily brought the mac and cheese um
and i thought that mac and cheese was
really good but you're saying it didn't
have the slices of the
spices on it she was making a cup of mac
and cheese like the instant cup of mac
and cheese and then i think draping a
slice over top of that as if it needed
more cheese
it always needs more chicken all right
so are you going with super powder on
this
uh i don't have a strong opinion i'm
going with i interpret this as hot
chocolate and we'll go with real
chocolate
all right um solve that one from
paradise
mythical noi uh how to pronounce pigeons
i say it's pigeon but my girlfriend
thinks it's
pigeons we googled it
and i think it says pigeons only but she
insists
that they are wrong p genes well p
p i i think agents i'm going to i'm
going to say
what i'm going with here i'm going to
just remove the p part
and i think this is a common um
you know this is a common mistake that
people make when there is a eo or
io in a word so you think that it looks
like there's two syllables in the second
half of the pigeon i think that's what's
up for debate
pigeon is that that's what it is pigeon
does pigeon is pigeon like a shortening
of the actual
word pigeon when you look at this you
see right here it's very clearly a
two-syllable word pidgin
pidgin pidgin is the correct
pronunciation
now i j upside down en
i could have consulted i think i may
have at some point
whether it's good mythical more or this
podcast i may have
already relayed this information but
my son shepard had this pigeon thing
that happened last year
and i don't mean like an incident with a
pigeon what i mean
is vaguely remember this he started at a
new school
right and at some point
he communicated to the class and to his
teacher
that he liked pigeons now let me be
clear
we didn't know that he liked pigeons he
had never talked about pigeons before to
us
i'm not saying he didn't like pigeons
just saying it didn't seem like it was
really that big of a thing but when
something you have to declare when he
went family
meeting please when he went out on this
picture to tell you all he went out on
this pigeon limb
and i think he saw that pigeons could
kind of be his thing
and that he was getting a response from
his classmates and his teachers and they
were like this is kind of funny this
kid's into pigeons like he drew
they had this one thing when you drew
yourself
as an animal and he drew himself as a
pigeon oh i remember this
it was beautiful and then the theme of
the entire year last year
or their school year and i'm talking
like the 2019
2020 so we were talking like fall 2019
uh was micronations right and so the
whole
idea was that you were going to get into
a group with some other students and you
were going to create a
fake a sort of fictional fictional
nation and and as you learn about like
the way economies work and the way
resources work and
you know in a in a nation you're going
to sort of create a story around a fake
nation and present it to the rest of the
class
as a way of embodying
these real things that exist in the
world but doing it in a fun fictitious
way right which we did with cheesustan
exactly so interestingly
there was another person in shepherd's
group that also had
strong opinions and it became a little
bit of a point of contention
when shepard suggested that the name of
their micronation be called paloma which
is
pigeon in spanish good name
and that the thing that was true about
paloma was the fact that it is just
a nation of pigeons
uh long story short shepard won this
argument
and paloma ended up being a nation of
pigeons
and it kind of became again
i ended up asking shepard about this and
i was like
shepard explain the explain the pigeon
thing to me and like how it happened and
he was like
because i was like i don't remember you
saying that you really liked pigeons
before this and he was like well
to be honest with you um
i said that it's not that i don't like
pigeons but i said that i like pigeons
and
everyone started reacting to it so i
just kind of leaned into it
so much so that this past year when he
started hit the new school year
and of course um
this new school year was very different
for the kids because they weren't in it
for they weren't in it for very long uh
because of covid
his teacher we had like a zoom
conference with his teacher and
and and she was like you know we love it
when shepard you know he doesn't always
participate but when he does participate
we love it when he participates and he's
he's funny and he tells funny stories
and also i would love to talk to him
about his love for pigeons and then she
holds up
a mug that has says something about
pigeons on the mug
and i'm like did this woman get this mug
or did she just
does she just have an affinity for
pigeons but like now that he's he's into
he has made this pigeon sort of yeah um
thing about himself it's part of him now
brand you have to kind of keep carrying
it on
so i wasn't going to break it to her
that you know the pigeon thing was just
something he kind of pulled out of his
butt and then leaned into
but she loves pigeons well she's like
she wanted to connect with him about
pigeons i was like yeah he'll love that
i don't know what i was saying like
pranking pranking the teacher i mean
this is well it's not much of a prank
because i mean
it's my kind of prank it's a very long
play prank
like again he's it's not i think he's
actually gotten more into pigeons
after as a result of this
self-fulfilling prophecy yeah
but i can just say he it's fair to say
he kind of got carried away
yes you know that was trying as i was
like
trying to be a carrier pigeon pun but i
get a little weak
as a as a father of a of a self
described pigeon lover
i can say pigeon is the correct
pronunciation is pg
is not pigeon pidgeon paloma is a place
in
in in california oh we can go visit
melbourne
where is it how far away is it it is uh
just southeast of sacramento
california i was almost watching the
family feud
just like right in the right in the i
was in the state i was watching the
family feud the other day which i
i love watching it okay and the question
was
name name a city or like
i i was like name a city that would you
would like to
go on vacation to anywhere in the world
right
okay and it was like okay so number one
answer was
hawaii
interestingly one of the guys said the
caribbean which is also not a city i
should be
i should be on family feud huh yeah you
would be a great contestant
you're you're a youtube highlight
waiting to happen i listen i want to be
on family
i seriously want to be on family feud uh
cities cities
titties are cities you gotta be clear
they're both they're both tough i mean
it's like once you say those words it's
like i get bombed what city what's the
city
what do you think is the number one
greece athens
and you've got two one you've got two
paris oh paris that's
you know like paris london i've been
there you know
rome oh rome not athens new york city
okay so you know those kinds of cities
but like los angeles
they were uh i don't think los angeles
was on there actually no maybe it was
paloma but it got down to this family
had two strikes
and like steve harvey is asking this
woman is like okay
you know the other family's gonna have
an opportunity to steal if you don't get
this
name a city that people would like to
vacation in and she's like
sacramento sacramento
oh i mean it's just like whoa okay
but steve didn't he didn't have as much
fun he just was like
sacramento okay sacramento he
he made a of course it wasn't up there
but disappointment he made the choice to
not
lean in and make fun of her too much
like he does a lot
well yeah it's not a four-hour show yeah
if he did that for every dumb answer
then you know what would happen
riker tweeted at us i want to get a
motorcycle
my wife thinks it's too unsafe
i work in a funeral home trust me people
die every day from all manner of
things mortality is a [ __ ] oh god this
is
this took an aggressive turn what should
i do
stay in bed wearing a helmet i want to
be alive
not just live um well
riker riker with a y i mean that's
the name really seems it adds up with
the motorcyclist you know if you've got
a
if you've got a y in your first name
i think you're much more likely to be a
uh a motorcyclist
i agree with that i think you're you're
living on the edge i think you're
willing to take more risk
because there are more risks and this is
a real conversation that happens a lot
with people wanting that a lot
well i i haven't i have a i got two fro
go ahead
i didn't mean to cut you an analogy go
ahead here because
i don't want to i don't want to ride a
motorcycle i don't want to own a
motorcycle
it's not i i i'm
too sensitive to like falling down
not just dying but i know that most
people who
own motorcycles are like how many times
have you have had this have you laid
this thing down like it happens like
yeah
it ends up happening you don't always
die but like i'm just in a place in my
life right now where
those kinds of inconveniencing injuries
let alone death it's not something i
want to entertain but
what i've said for years is that i've
been very interested
in ultra light flying right we talked
about this before
and then there's many times where i've
thought of myself like i should get my
pilot's license i should
fly a little plane right anytime i bring
this up with my wife
she's like no
now she was in a plane crash that makes
a difference
um she was too young to remember it but
when she was it did happen when she was
less than one
year old her parents were in a small
plane
that clipped a power line
and crashed and no one was no one was
seriously injured
but anyway it's like this sort of
there's a sort of this lore in her
family and first of all
there's how often do you hear about
somebody dying in a small plane it seems
like it's pretty odd
pretty often right so but i
and so i've kind of dropped this i've
kind of been like all right i'm not
going to push this
but for me the only way to because i
know that it is more dangerous like
me not getting a pilot's license me not
ultra light flying is a safer long-term
life choice than me
deciding to do it right but we don't
just like riker said we don't just
avoid all risk right what do i do stay
in bed wearing a helmet he wants to be
alive not just
live so to me this is an individual
because i mean i'm being serious about
this i'm not trying to make a joke about
this
this is a thing that lots of people
argue about and i'm
in and it isn't just always well the the
husband wants to do something dangerous
and the wife wants to keep him from it
that that happens a lot of times but i'm
just saying in any relationship there
might be something that you want to do
that there is inherent risk in it and we
know that it is
risky or significantly riskier to ride a
motorcycle
than to be in a car 27 times as likely
to die
in a motorcycle crash than a car crash
right because for obvious reasons you're
riding on top of the vehicle you're not
inside the view
not inside the vehicle and that's
according to the national highway
traffic and safety administration we're
familiar with them we've
we've made videos for them yeah 27 times
more likely
uh to die so but how do you evaluate
this right because
then in a car what if riker's number one
passion
in life is to ride a motorcycle now
if this is something that developed
after they got married
and now you you know what you have to
take into account the fact that your
wife doesn't want you to do this
now if you were like a motorcycle guy
is part of your identity you're super
into it before you got married when you
get into a relationship
that i think feel like that's a
different conversation because it's like
you married this person
you got into this relationship knowing
that this is a passion of theirs
changing them you're gonna have to live
with that risk that's a complicating
factor it does change the complexion of
the conference but let's just assume
this is
happening after the relationship i don't
even know that you you have to be
prepared you know it's i
i still think it it's probably a
decision for the two of you but
you know yeah you still got to come to
you still got to come to a decision but
it is different if it was a pre-existing
condition it is
motorcycle love we we know two people
mike and nick who were had motorcycles
and then uh well mike was in more
more of an accident than i think nick
was but like when they
when nick started having children it was
like there was a negotiation
or discussions that led to him
getting rid of his motorcycle yeah right
um i mean
there's a lot of technique and skill
and it it's a demanding hobby
you know to be really good at it and to
to be
defensive in your driving and to be
aware of everything because it's like
there's so much constant risk i you know
and there's certainly
parameters i don't know what they are
but i would think there are parameters
that would make it
more safe like he's i'm kind of guessing
here so i'm
you know talking out of school but
when you're like motorcyclists traveling
in groups
you know it's like if you've got a buddy
you're saying more likely
i mean there are things you can do to
mitigate your risk i think that might be
one of them
you know you're more you're more visible
in a group
and wear an orange shirt wear a bright
helmet i'm saying
join a motorcycle gang okay well okay
or yeah and probably wear like really
bright colors
so you're saying that like a just like a
clown the approach to
the motorcycling and how like if you're
a motorcycle stunt person if you're like
oh well i'm gonna be a a tick tick-tock
or an instagram
motorcycle person and i'm going to do
like wheelies down the middle of the
interstate
without a helmet in a bikini right then
that's probably that's problematic on a
number of levels
i agree with that but i feel like the
factors are
if you really i guess what i'm getting
is if you really care about it
if if i'm riker i might can do a bunch
of research to then bring that
20 that stat of 27 times more likely
to die than in a car i might could bring
that stat down
with you know classes so
you know there's certain things certain
stipulations okay you can minimize
yourself so you might can minimize it
but you're still going to be
more responsible but i i think that i'm
trying to use the motorcycle thing
as as something that represents anything
that a partner wants to do that's higher
risk whether it's small planes or
anything even me for
mountain biking like i've come home a
few times and we've
gone off on new trails and i did tell
christy and i was like i don't know why
i'm telling her this but i said
you know i was on this trail that if i
would have fallen off my bike
the wrong way i think i would have died
and that's not a that's not a good thing
yeah and uh
i don't think i'm gonna go on that trail
again and i'm pretty cautious
you know so like when i get to those
places
i try like sometimes i'll walk my bike
so i don't i'm i'm increasingly more
risk averse
but it did but it but it is a risky
thing
well so on some of these singles so
let's assume just just to
kind of arrive at some conclusion for
riker
that this is a passion that developed
after the relationship started so we've
doing away from that
factor and let's assume that if riker
decides to do this
he's going to do it in as safe as a way
as he can right he's going to be a safe
and responsible motorcyclist
still riskier than not deciding to be a
motorcyclist and
and to ride in a car right to me
the factors at play are i think he has a
point
in terms of well this is something i
want to do and i recognize that it's
risky and i'm gonna die at some point
okay there's a point there
but i think that it's like how resistant
is your wife to this and then how
passionate
are you about is this like you've
determined that this is something that
you
have to have in order to live a full
life because i do believe there might be
some people who would say that it's like
if i don't get to do if i don't get to
go skydiving if i don't get to do this
thing if i don't get to be a rock
climber
yeah then i'm not fulfilling my passion
and i think that
this is a every couple has to answer
this
because it might get to a point where
it's just like this is a risky thing
you might die but i can tell that you're
committed to this again it might be the
kind of thing like this whole ultra
light flying thing when my kids finally
leave
or on their own and i and i
really have a midlife crisis not just
like a little bit of one like i've been
having
like a real one and i'm like baby either
i get a convertible or i
or i start flying planes there's one or
the other
you know what i'm saying like i i think
at some point
it could get both depending on your life
stage are you still or you're
how old are you you still got kids who
are depending on you as a father
what you know i think there's a lot of
different factors that go into this i
just don't think there's a
straight answer to this yeah but i think
if if you really care about it
and you and it's it's a negotiation
and you might have to go so far as to
say well okay
if the worst happens have i have i take
have i really looked at the risk and
taken into account meaning
i'm getting a life insurance policy
and by the way you have to tell them
that you got a motorcycle
and they're going to charge you that
much more so like there's this
kind of this arbitration thing that's
like if you're not willing to
to do what it takes to take care of your
family to accommodate for that risk
then maybe you're not you're not as
committed as you need to be to do it
because
you so you say if if i am in a
motorcycle crash you'll get rich
how's that sound well i'm gonna take
care i'm gonna i'm gonna
take out a policy that's gonna make sure
you're taken care of
so i'm not just like leaving you in a
lurch because i had to
not just live but be alive and in the
end it's a negotiation
regardless of your intentions regardless
of how safe you are how much you're
willing to sacrifice for the risk
regardless of all the insurance that you
have in place if your partner
still says i'm not comfortable with this
i think part of being in a relationship
is to be like okay i'm gonna give up on
this
that you can find something hey what
about one of those three-wheeled bikes
just
start adding wheels and see if that's
better yeah
yeah i mean you're adding a wheel and a
lot of investments that's what the
spider market is all about you just
you just unlocked it in my mind it's
it's men who wanted a motorcycle whose
wives were not comfortable with it
yeah so they got one of those three
wheelers
that's what it is yeah and then you know
what maybe you need a fourth wheel
i don't think it's got a car well that's
your problem i think you need
you're going the wrong direction once
you get to three wheels then you
negotiate down to
two oh you're talking about like a
literal three-wheeled motorcycle
i'm talking about those spiders that how
come in front yeah i'm talking about
that
because there's a three-wheel motorcycle
too there's two wheels in the back
which i think those are more dangerous
than a regular motorcycle
well you got to get your facts straight
this is not this is not
my negotiation i mean but is this the
type of thing that like i mean if
you know w we're not willing to go in
this business but there's somebody out
there
who can be more of an arbitration expert
for
for decisions like this like i wonder if
there's someone on the premises of the
motorcycle dealership
that steps in as an as for arbitration
in couples
no to help sell the bike no the there's
a lot of psychology there i'd like to
talk to a motorcycle salesman the
motorcycle salesman
is only equipping the person trying to
buy the motorcycle with arguments that
then go home and tell your wife
yeah that's that's it exclusively so
riker you might want to do that too
go go to your local dealer and say hey
listen
they probably you got to give me a
pamphlet they they probably have a pam
they got a pamphlet if you want to sell
something to a motorcycle
salesman it's a pamphlet that they just
give to people who want to buy
motorcycles
oppai be safe out there riker yeah
whatever you decide
wear an orange helmet opossum queen
at work i drive a truck that is shared
between shifts i am one of the shorter
people
and a lot of people complain about my
seat position when they drive after me
should we be adjusting our seat for the
next person
or just adjust it for yourself at the
beginning of the shift
okay i mean as a six seven man with a
five foot three wife
who who share a car okay
this is a very relevant question and you
got a fancier car so how does it
actually work
in your car she's number one and i'm
number two yeah
so if you hit number one it becomes
jessie's
but when you again goes to her position
where is it when you get in
it's wherever it was the last time
somebody got out really
well then okay you're not quite as fancy
as as you need to be
this isn't a competition but my car
here's what it does when i turn off the
car and then i open the door
the seat goes all the way back so no
matter who you are or how
short or tall or how forward it was it
goes all the way back and then it's easy
for everybody to get out
and then when you get and then the next
person to get in it's all the way back
and then it
goes forward to that position
yes does that what it does i think
technically if i was if i really wanted
and i think the answer is in there
is that my key and her key
tell the car who's getting in the car
but we lost one of the keys
because we're the mclaughlin oh that's
advanced so there's just one key to the
car
and uh it's hers i'm talking
i'm not talking about what my my daily
driver i'm talking about like the family
car that she drives but i drive
occasionally
and because it's just but you can you
even but if it's in her position
you can't even get in i would break i
would break a femur trying to get in
like when
lily when i have i drove lily's car the
old sion i had to drive it in because i
forgot to charge my car and
if lily drove right before me she sits
so much closer
yeah i can't i can't get in lincoln
can't get it but it's so obvious when i
opened the door like it's not like i
would ever
make the mistake of trying to get in you
almost like reach down there
if you told me for a hundred thousand
dollars
sit in this seat couldn't do it couldn't
do it it could be like a challenge on
survivor and i would and i would lose
and so i i immediately can tell that
this is not made for me and so i just
hit the number two and wait
even when the car is not on it still
works yeah
huh so i wonder if opossum queen's truck
it seems like i'm assuming this is not
this is not an automatic situation
queen you need to move that seat back
listen if you're
you're one of the shorter people and you
you're you're receiving complaints
uh-huh about seat position hey le i mean
i think i think you should uh i think
you should move your seat back and i
think it would also
make it it's not difficult for you to
get out but it will make it that much
easier
so it's like a win-win you you slam the
seat all the way back
you have even more room to just dash out
of that thing and you're being
considerate
this is your co-worker you're saying
that this is something that
only applies to the short people because
you're what you're saying
it's a little discriminatory because the
tall people
they just get in and get out and they
don't have to do anything because you're
saying that
everyone from short to tall is
accommodated
in the getting in and out of the car
process if the seat is back
yeah and then if you're a short person
you bring it up while driving and then
you
take it down i think the shorter people
have to defer to the taller people than
this one
especially in a work environment i mean
if this is
you know if this is just your family car
you know screw them you know they don't
put their cups away anyway
so don't put your seat back you know
give them a little jab
but this is an easy way for you to to
not get demerits on the job
i don't know if i i understand the logic
of what you're saying
and i understand why it doesn't apply to
the tall people because it's not like
the tall person can be like you know a
short person might get in this car after
me i'm going to put the seat up
before i get out first of all it's
impossible to put the seat up before you
get out if you're tall
you have to get out of the truck and
then like manipulate the seat from the
ground
yeah so the short person does have the
ability to move the seat up and back
i do think just because of the way
physics work this is
uh the short people are gonna get the
short end of the stick in this situation
and because when i try to get in lily's
car i did notice that i would
sit in and then reach down and adjust
the seat back but it's like
very difficult for me to get in the car
some of the most uncomfortable moments
of your life but
but i i did that instead of bending all
the way over to reach under the seat and
push it back because then you got like a
back injury you know i mean
that again it's like we gotta you gotta
calculate our risk in everything
at our age yeah a possum queen take one
for the team
sorry girl i think there's there's one
more that i don't even think requires
any discussion
it we can just softball set it up knock
it out of the part
from hit me um rebellious mary
my boyfriend thinks the blinds closes
slats down when they clearly should be
closed slats up
the light comes through still when he
closes them down
that's not enough evidence for him he
thinks closing them down
will prevent peepers what do you all
think
i'm with her mary you're right i mean
this is this is so lines go up
people still can't see in and it blocks
the it blocks the light from
shining through that little slit onto
the floor well
case in point just yesterday i'm on a on
a zoom call
and i'm facing a window in the in my
my office in the creative house faces
the window
and uh i don't know if it was me or
somebody else that close
this close them slats down and it was
sunny and there were these lines all
over my desk
and my face and so i immediately turned
them
slats up and it was this nice even light
and no you can't see through it if
they're making their
advantage to slides down it looks nicer
it looks smoother to be down for them to
be down that's the only thing i can come
up with the way it's like
it seems like it's just it seems like
that's the right way to do it because it
makes it smooth it's like
scales on the back of a snake it's kind
of like rubbing
rubbing a cat the wrong direction when
you when you turn those blinds up it's a
little unsettling
to me you've complicated it now but i
believe that it's right
functionally functionally i cannot think
of
of any other reason to have them
go the other way except for the scales
of a snake well all i gotta say is your
boyfriend's stated reason is he thinks
that
this will prevent peepers and it's just
not it's not true
they can't can't you can't prevent
peepers people's gonna pee yeah the
people are still outside the window
regardless of how you've got the blinds
we should give a heads up we're
releasing a special episode of
uh your biscuits uh this coming thursday
if you're listening to this one fresh
on monday then just a few days later we
got a
special extra i'm gonna call it a mini
episode
i don't think it's gonna be as long as a
typical one uh
it's part of the dell podference uh so
we're gonna be talking about how
we weathered covid from a business
standpoint so
don't be alarmed when there's a there's
a an entirely
extra mini ear biscuit later this week
just want to give you that heads up
and i'm i'll close with a wreck here um
i'm choosing this wreck because i
believe that it is it could be a point
of contention
um and that is if you are a
just i'll start with if you are a blue
cheese lover
or you are blue cheese tolerant some
people don't like the taste of blue
cheese
i can't this is not going to be helpful
for you okay i'm checking out then
um go online
find the recipe for blue cheese coleslaw
there's one on food network that's
that's good
my wife when i was talking earlier about
the uh
having you guys over for the for the
pork shoulder that i i
i i very good i smoked this very
shoulder for 17 hours
okay it was like 23 pounds i ate it over
the course of
like 14 minutes my uh wife
was like of course we got to make slaw
for this thing because we're doing it
you know in north carolina style and she
was like what do you think what do you
think if i made
uh a blue cheese slaw i was like first
of all i love this idea
second of all you can't just make a blue
cheese slaw you have to make a regular
slaw yeah for
people who don't like blue cheese but i
love this idea
and she made it and for me as a blue
cheese lover
it was revolutionary it has changed the
way i think about slow i was not a slaw
person
i put slaw on my barbecue almost
out of obligation because i'm from north
carolina
to be honest with you it isn't like i
like it it's kind of like yeah yeah
this is what you do try the blue cheese
slaw and again
if you're a blue cheese lover or if
you're just blue cheese tolerant if
you're the kind of person that if
there's blue cheese in something it
throws everything off for you don't try
it you're not gonna like it but i'm just
gonna tell you right now
try it before you knock it
i like it blue cheese slaw
okay hashtag gear biscuits again we'll
see you for a special one
on thursday and then a normal one like
every other monday
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right
to watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best